Wooo we are live. Authors publishing ten books a week with a chatbot. Grandma googles and never leaves Google. An eight-minute site that sells zero. This is Episode Fifteen. We walk you to office 360 dot com.
I'm Morgan. Amazon 2026 slop. Bill Johns, hundreds of titles, ten books a week at Amazon's cap. A vending machine in a cardigan. Real authors standing in a blizzard of paperbacks nobody asked for.
Zero click. AI Overviews. The sidewalk answers and your site is a party with no guests. The eight-minute website: pretty lobby, buy button to nowhere. The fix is a doorbell.
The eight-minute site hallucinates calendars and example.com carts. If AI writes the sidewalk, your house must be findable when someone knocks. Book. Store. Done.
The Office 360. Four seniors. Lisbon to New York. You own the code. Three-click discoverability. office 360 dot com. STUDIO50. Half off. A house with keys, not a vending machine.
You cannot out-slop the slop. Email theofficetechies@gmail.com: Story Time, Shout Out, Advertise, Donate. Then office 360 dot com.
Ten books a week should be in a museum. Real IA, real HTTPS, real forms, real ownership. office 360 dot com. STUDIO50. A true book with a doorbell outlives a blizzard of slop.
Mailbox: Story Time, Shout Out, Advertise, Donate. Pretend you just left an AI overview. Three taps to the book. office 360 dot com.
Landing. Blizzard of paperbacks, sidewalk answers, eight-minute lobby. office 360 dot com. STUDIO50. Subscribe. Download. Tell an aunt. The doorbell works.
Episode Fifteen. Ten books a week, zero clicks, eight-minute websites, doorbell at office 360 dot com. Email us. Listen. Download. Subscribe. Bye!